today on Chalk radio we're expanding our
traditional understanding of economics
at the end of the day what economists
should be trying to do or economics
should try to do is maximize people's
well-being
I'm your host Sarah Hansen today we're
talking about economics and well-being
from exploring the impact of Trends in
decision making to dissecting why
students procrastinate Dr Frank shilbach
is working to understand how our
psychological well-being impacts our
economic behaviors and vice versa
my name is Frank schilbach I'm an
associate professor at MIT in the
economics Department I study mostly
issues related to Poverty studying
development economics with developing
countries and I'm specifically
interested in issues that
disproportionately affect the poor that
are in one way or the other
psychological or have psychological
effects these include sleep deprivation
physical pain loneliness mental distress
or mental health issues such as
depression or anxiety or just worries
about money and all of these factors
might affect people's psychological
well-being they might also have impacts
on people's decision making such as how
much money to save whether to purchase
insurance or what food to eat or
purchase as well as people's work
decisions so how productive people are
at work how many hours they work how
much do they earn and all together these
might affect people's ability to escape
poverty or become richer in the future
and thus as a whole perhaps lead to what
people might call a psychological
poverty trap app because they have to
struggle with so many issues associated
with poverty their sleeping conditions
are bad
struggled with mental distress Etc
[Music]
actors in his work Frank's model of
Economics diverges from many traditional
models
our lab is really the world
we can look around and talk to people
every day and experience things try to
introspect how we make decisions
ourselves but also talk to people and
try to understand and you can take a cab
or an Uber and just ask your Uber driver
how they're making choices on whether or
not to stop working or how much to work
you can ask anybody on your friends and
so on try to understand how they make
choices in their lives and what factors
seem important
some of the research I've been doing on
sleep but also on alcohol consumption on
mental health comes very much from this
type of approach I spent some time in
India trying to work on some research
projects and while working on these
research projects to spend a lot of time
talking to people so would have lots of
conversations with people asking them
their basic things about what are things
that make you happy what are things that
are difficult in your life what are
things that you think that could be
improved or if you could improve one
thing in your life what would you do and
so on and a lot of the things that I'm
now studying are precisely issues that
are in some ways overlooked by or have
until recently at least not received a
lot of attention in economics so far for
example say sleep deprivation
yet they seemed really important in part
because if you just look at people's
sleeping conditions they are replete
with all sorts of factors that are
terrible for people's sleep and this is
where the introspection comes in if you
then think about how do you function on
a really bad night of sleep you know
that's very difficult at least for me so
if I sleep badly I'm very sensitive to
sleep I I don't function particularly
well and putting these things together
has then gotten me interested in
understanding and researching the impact
of improving sleep on people's lives
intuitively I know sleep deprivation is
bad I feel grumpy and impatient and get
frustrated more easily when I don't get
enough sleep but I had no idea it might
affect how much money I make and how
much money I save
D so what we did in one of our studies
we tried to provide people with
different interventions to improve their
sleep including eye shades earplugs
mattress table fan and so on so these
are all kind of interventions to improve
your sleep environment we also gave
people some information about doctors
say you know sleep is important for your
health and other people were given
incentives to sleep more so they're
actually paid by the number of hours
that they slept and the more they slept
the more they were paid
and all of these interventions were in
fact quite successful in increasing
people's sleep and what we were then
interested in is now if you increase
your sleep does it improve different
aspects so if you're live ranging from
cognition so these are just measures of
attention work productivity so we hired
people for a month to work as data entry
workers so then we looked at people's
labor Supply how many hours did people
work how productive were they how fast
did they work how many mistakes did they
make and so on how much money did they
earn overall and so is it the case that
if you sleep more now do you make more
money at work on an everyday basis and
then we looked at other things such as
savings we gave people an attractive
savings opportunities you look at do
people save more when they sleep more as
well as the economists would call
preferences which is time risk and
social preferences so how do you make
decisions over time how pro-social are
you when you decide between your own
outcomes versus others how how nice are
you to others and how do you make
decisions in the face of risk and the
idea here would be that if you found
effects people might for example be more
patient if they have slept more so they
might be willing to save more for the
future which could have high returns in
the future
at MIT Frank's work in behavioral
economics seeks to enhance current
economic models with insights from
anthropology and sociology in order to
make the field of Economics reflect what
actually goes on in people's lives I
asked Frank to explain a bit more about
how his work Builds on traditional
economic models
economics makes a lot of very Stark
assumptions on people's behavior so
economics usually your standard
economics usually assumes that people
are very rational they're very willful
they're also very well informed and very
attentive
so you can think of this and this is
usually called homoeconomic because this
is a person sort of the ideal human who
doesn't make any mistakes who makes
perfect decisions
and is always right in what they do and
they perfectly optimize at any point in
time
Frank explained that although standard
economics Frameworks do help explain a
lot of important behaviors
their assumptions often miss some
important parts of people's choices
looking through a psychological lens can
help round out the picture
there are a number of examples in which
psychological insights have been quite
important in informing models one very
successful area is the area of
self-control or decision making over
time this is the question on when we
have unpleasant tasks that we might not
want to do for example when we choose
when to do certain things or when to
consume earlier versus later when there
are Temptations on when people try to
procrastinate people tend to have
imperfect self-control so we don't
always do the things we plan to do we
don't always plan to do the things we
want to do on time students
procrastinate their problem sets faculty
procrastinate writing their problem sets
people consume too early people overeat
people over indulge in things they are
joyful in the moment but have perhaps
long-run consequences and people under
invest in things that are painful in the
Moment Like say going to the gym or
going to the doctor or making good
health choices that are in fact then
costly in the future
and so behavioral economics has then
tried to model or try to understand
self-control problems or what people
call present Focus which is people
excessively focus on the present they've
put lots of weight on what they
experience right now if you have a donut
in front of you it's hard to resist
or if you're in bed in the morning and
think about you to exercise early or
should I sleep for another hour it might
be very tempting to say well I'd rather
sleep another hour even though your plan
was very much to get up early and
exercise and be virtuous and so on and
so now behavioral economics has helped
us understand such issues and potential
ways to overcome them through what
people call commitment devices for
example which are essentially contracts
or type of policies that might help
people overcome self-control issues
that's interesting I also think
especially what you say about using
insights from anthropology to inform
standard models like insights from
community members and anthropologists
working with community members it might
look like someone is not making an
informed decision once you start looking
into the Community Network a decision
that might not seem rational might
actually be very rational in that
particular context like they might be
making decisions based on ties to other
community members or reciprocity or you
know things that would benefit them in
other ways that these standardized
models might miss and I think it might
be a way to make economics more
culturally relevant or informed
that's exactly right so in a way you
might see people's choices and think
that they're making irrational choices
one way or the other
but in fact it's that our models are
mispecified so typically our definition
of rationality is to say we can have a
set of choices or preferences we can
have some model of your behavior that
explains what you're doing overall and
if you can have such a model then we can
rationalize your behavior in some ways
and we say certain choices are rational
now if you make certain choices where
our existing models say this does not
compute this does not add up it doesn't
seem right
one might be tempted to say while these
choices appear irrational
but in fact they're not irrational it's
just we have mispecified the model we
have misunderstood we have forgotten or
or omitted certain factors that seem
important and those could be exactly as
you say like social or cultural factors
how people care about others or how
people care about others influences
potentially and that could be really
important
[Music]
before we get back to our interview with
Frank we wanted to take a moment to
thank all of our listeners who have
written to us with appreciation feedback
and questions for our guests
we also wanted to thank those of you
who've left us ratings and reviews on
Apple podcasts hearing how much you're
enjoying the show means a lot to us
so we thought it might be a good idea to
share some of these reviews from time to
time on the show starting with this one
which also happens to include a
suggestion it says
I am very thankful that this podcast
exists as mentioned in the trailer it is
close to being able to have a quick
conversation with these great professors
about their interesting courses I love
the episode with Gilbert Strang and look
forward to listening to subjects that I
would not normally be exposed to
suggestion please do an episode on 6001
with Dr Annabelle Professor Eric crimson
and professor John gutake
wow what a great review thank you so
much so interestingly Eric Grimson was
recently named interim vice president
for open learning which technically
means he's my colleague now and you know
I think he'd probably be into the idea
of appearing on Chalk radio so why don't
I give him a call right now
foreign
hi Eric this is Sarah from chalk radio
hi Sarah how are you doing
I'm doing great hey um we got a request
to have you on the show
um to talk about computer programming
and I'm wondering if you'd be up for
that I'd love to it'd be great right
just let me know when and where I'll be
there great we'll be in touch and we'll
talk soon
well there you have it you can look
forward to an interview with Eric
Crimson later this season on Chalk radio
and if you have a suggestion for a guest
you'd like to hear on Chalk radio you
can let us know in a review on Apple
podcasts or Spotify or you can email us
directly at chalkradio mit.edu
okay now back to our interview with
Frank schilbach
it's clear students mental health is an
important factor for Frank and he takes
that into account in the way he
structures his course
when I started my problem since we do at
9am or whenever in class essentially at
the beginning of class and that's very
standard in many classes at MIT
but of course what that leads to is
students like pulling all-nighters or
doing the problem sets in the middle of
the night which you know arguably is not
good for them or good for their health
or their mental health for that matter
and so now I shifted to to having
problems that do at 6 PM or 8 PM in fact
on Fridays in part because I want
students to to have some weekends and
again not work in the middle of the
night so very small choices that I like
to think are well informed by at least
some behavioral economics or
psychological considerations yeah it
also pushes Mental Health and Wellness
out of this cordoned off area that like
oh yeah it's important to think about
but we're gonna like consider all these
other things first you're really pulling
it into the center of what you're doing
which is I think a pretty unique
approach to teaching
yeah I think that's right I think it's
also in economics more broadly mental
health at least until recently has not
received a lot of attention so in some
of the research that I have been doing
it's still viewed as in some ways
instrumental in the sense that you say
well if you can improve people's mental
health we can improve people's
productivity or their decision making or
other types of outcomes
what I increasingly think is is in fact
more important is just mental health by
itself as an outcome is what we should
strive for
of course that's very hard to measure in
some ways in the sense that economists
believe in choices and hard outcomes
such as productivity or earnings or the
like that are easier to measure and
mental health is much more difficult to
measure in some ways
but at the end of the day what
economists should be trying to do or
economics should try to do is maximize
people's well-being
all right my last question
so on your ocw website page there's an
image of a credit card frozen in ice in
a glass
so 30 second answer should we all be
freezing our credit cards
at some point I was showing my wife this
exact slide with this exact example
and she was done just telling me well
haven't you seen Confessions of a
Shopaholic which in fact is this movie
where somebody exactly has this approach
and the bottom line from that movie is
well there's a person who really likes
to shop and she has in fact Frozen her
credit card
and then once the shop gets the credit
card out of the freezer but then just
spends a lot of time with trying to
unfreeze their credit card and then
shops anyway so you want to be kind of
careful with these types of policies are
they really achieving the behavior that
you want to achieve as in like does it
really make you shop less if you would
like to do so or does it just make
things more convenient and you're kind
of circumventing these types of policies
or these types of things that you set
out to do in the first place so if it's
just then you put your credit card into
the freezer then you unfreeze it by
putting it into the bathtub or the lake
then you just put in a lot of effort and
Shop anyway and so you might as well
have just shopped in the first place if
that makes you happy
Frank's approach of including societal
factors such as mental health and
economic models is what makes his work
so important and what makes economics
feel so human and accessible if you are
ready to dive into teaching or learning
with his materials you can find them on
our MIT open courseware website
there you'll find his 23 video lectures
lecture slides recitation notes problem
sets with Solutions and quizzes with
Solutions all available for reuse and
remixing and all for free you can help
others find the materials too by
subscribing to this podcast and leaving
us a rating and review
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from Cambridge
Massachusetts I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT open courseware
MIT chalk radio's producers include
myself Brett Pache and Dave leshansky
our scriptwriter is nidhi shastri
show notes for this episode were written
by Peter Chipman Frank Showbox ocw
coresight was built by Cheryl Siegel
we're funded by MIT open learning and
supporters like you